so you mentioned dreaming you've played
around with some out there fascinating
ideas how do you think when and we'll
start diving into the world of the very
small ideas of supersymmetry and all
that in terms of visualization in terms
of how do you think about it how do you
dream of it how do you come up with
ideas in that fascinating mysterious
space so in my workspace which is
basically where I am charged with coming
upon on coming up on a mathematical
palette with new ideas that will help me
understand the structure of nature and
hopefully help for all of us understand
structure of nature I've observed
several different ways in which my
creativity expresses itself there's one
mode which looks pretty normal which I
sort of think of as the Chinese water
torture myth it is drop drop drop you
get more and more information and
suddenly it all congeals and you get a
clearer picture and so that's the kind
of a standard way of working and I think
that's how most people think about the
way technical people solve problems that
it's kind of you accumulate this body of
information at a certain point you
synthesize it and then boom there's
something new but I've also observed in
myself and other scientists that there
are other ways that we are creative
creative and these other ways to me are
actually far more powerful I first
personally experienced this when I was a
freshman at MIT live over in Baker house
right across the campus and I was in a
calculus course 1801 is called at MIT
and calculus comes in two different
flavors one of them is called
differential calculus the other is
called integral calculus differential
calculus is the calculus that Newton
invented to describe motion since our
integral calculus was probably invented
about 1700 years earlier by Archimedes
but we didn't know that when I was a
freshman but so that's what you study as
a student and the differential calculus
part of the course was to me I wouldn't
how do I say this it was something that
that by the driptip method you could
sort of figure it out now the integral
part of calc
this I could memorize the formula that
was not the formula that was not the
problem the problem was why in my own
mind why do these formulae work and
because of that when I was in the part
of the calculus course where we had to
do multiple substitutions to solve
integrals I had a lot of difficulty I
was emotionally involved in my education
because this is where I think the
passion emotion comes to and it caused
an emotional crisis that I was having
these difficulties understanding the
integral part of calculus so why
otherwise that's right the why of it not
the remember rote memorization of fact
but the why of it why does this work and
so one night I was over in my dormitory
room in Baker house I was trying to do a
calculus problem set I was getting
nowhere I got a terrific headache I went
to sleep and had this very strange dream
and when I woke walk awakened I could do
3 & 4 substitutions and integrals with
relative ease now this to me wasn't an
astounding experience because I had
never before in my life understood that
one subconscious is actually capable of
being harnessed to do mathematics I
experienced it this and I've experienced
this more than once so this was just the
first time why I remember it so so
that's why when it comes to like really
wickedly tough problems I think that the
kind of creativity that you need to
solve them is probably this second
variety which comes somehow from
dreaming if you think again I told you
I'm Russian so we romanticize suffering
but do you think part of that equation
is the suffering leading up to that
dreaming so the suffering is I am
convinced that this kind of creative
sick the second mode of creativity as I
like to call it I'm convinced that this
second mode of creativity is in fact
that suffering is a kind of crucible
that triggers it because the mine I
think is struggling to get out of this
and the only the only
he was actually solved the problem and
even though you're not consciously
solving problems something is going on
and I've talked about to a few other
people in there are there similar
stories and so I the way I guess so I
think about it is it's a little bit by
like the way that thermonuclear weapons
work and if you know how they work but a
thermonuclear weapon is actually two
bombs there's an atomic bomb which sort
of Delta compression and then you have a
fusion bomb that goes off and somehow
that emotional pressure
I think acts like the first stage of a
thermonuclear weapon that's when we get
really big thoughts the analogy between
thermonuclear weapons and the
subconscious the the connection there is
uh at least visually that's kind of
interesting well I there may be fried it
would have a few things to say well part
of it is probably based on my own
trajectory through life my father was in
the Army for us for the US Army for 27
years and so I started my life out on
military bases and so a lot of probably
the things that wander around in my
subconscious are connected to the
experience
you